let's consider a ball that is dropped
from a certain height H I above the
ground and this ball is falling it hits
the ground and it bounces up until it
reaches some final height H final now
when the ball is colliding with the
ground there are collision forces and in
this problem what we'd like to do is
figure out what the average force of the
ground is on the ball so we'd like to
find B and that will be the normal force
the average normal force on the ball
during the collision now if we look at
this all dropping it's going to lose a
little bit of energy because it's
getting compressed at the collision
let's look at an example of the actual
ball dropping as you can see in this
high-speed video as the ball falls down
it collides with the ground when it
collides with the ground it's compressed
and then as it rebounds upwards the ball
expands back to its original shape but
it doesn't quite get to the same height
that's because when the ball is
compressed there's some deformation in
the rubber structure of the ball and
it's not a completely elastic
deformation and so some of the energy is
transformed into first different
molecular motions which turn into
thermal energy that's radiated into the
environment let's look in particular at
the details of the collision if we look
at it in slow motion what we have here
and I'll draw a picture as the ball is
colliding with the ground the ball
compresses expands as it goes upwards
and so we can draw a Freebody diagram on
the ball
with a normal force and a gravitational
force now let's choose our positive
direction up so now what we'd like to do
is apply the momentum principle to
analyze the average normal force and our
momentum principle remember is impulse
the force integrated over some time
during the collision is equal to the
change
in momentum so what we'd like to do is
identify the states that are relevant so
we'll have a state before so what we'll
do is we'll call this the before state
and that's right before the ball is
hitting the ground and we have an after
state and in the after state the ball
has now finished colliding with the
background and it's now moving up with
speed up now again we're gonna choose
positive up here I'm representing things
as speeds one of the things we need
sometimes here so let's say that at T
initial is zero this is our final time
we'll call this time the before time
we'll just call this T before and this
is T after and then our integral is
going from before to after of the
momentum and we can now apply the
momentum principle well this is a vector
equation and we've chosen unit vectors
up so what we have here is the integral
of from T before to T after of n minus
mg integrated over DT and that's equal
to the momentum at the Y component of
the momentum at T after minus the Y
component of the momentum we don't have
a vector here anymore the Y component of
the vector T before and so this is our
expression of the momentum principle
impulse causes momentum to change now
we're assuming that the normal force is
just averaging it and so this integral
simply becomes an average minus mg times
the time of collision is equal to now in
here we can put the mass of the ball we
have the velocity now here's where we
have to be a little bit careful because
we're looking at the Y component we
chose speed down
that's in the negative y-direction so we
have - sorry we're looking at V after we
have plus the after because this is
going in the positive J hat direction
and over here we have negative mass but
it's going in the minus direction so we
have minus MV before and so we get mass
times V after + V before so our first
result is that the normal force average
let's bring the divide through by delta
T and bring the mg term over so we have
M VA plus VB divided by delta T plus M G
so we see that if the collision time is
very short
then this average force is a little bit
bigger a long collision time the average
force a little bit smaller now from
kinematics we already have worked out
the problem that the speed for an object
that rises to a height H final this is
the velocity afterwards is just square
root of 2gh final and in a similar way
if an object is falling a height H I the
speed when it gets to the bottom is 2 G
H I and so now we can conclude with
these substitutions that the average
force equals M times square root of 2 G
H final + square root of 2gh initial
over the collision time plus and G and
of course the collision time we're
saying is T after - T before and so
that's how we can use the momentum
principle to get an average expression
for the normal force